hello guys welcome to a new video on
codetech tutorials today we're going to
be looking at another way to do your c
plus plus gooeys or interfaces or
windowing
and just kind of continuing the trend
for a little bit longer today we're
looking at cute creator yes it's
pronounced cute not qt and as you can
see here
cute creator a cross platform ide for
application development so yes they have
their own ide
now you can use your own ide you don't
have to use cube creator but q creator
is really nice
because it allows you to design your
interface with a nice designer
application that way you can see what
you're doing and see what things are
going to look like before you hit your
launch button now that being said you
don't have to use this uh
it's like an xml markup sort of like
html in case you don't know that they
use and you don't have to use it you can
put just c plus plus code right in there
to tell it what to do as well and not
use any markup language but i would
highly recommend using the markup
because i've tried both and i feel like
using the xml was a little easier for
scaling into larger forms but if you're
just doing maybe small stuff and with
some very basic things then just using
the code and doing away with the forms
might be fine as well
if you download cute here and get the
ide it's gonna it's gonna prompt for you
to go ahead and get the libraries and
it's gonna set up a lot of your stuff
for you and you can see you can buy it
this is often used for like just
integrated stuff cars
uh planes
a lot of embedded stuff likes to use
cute or a lot of companies use it rather
and this is one of the first ones i used
when i was a new coder and i loved it so
i'm pretty excited to get back into it
so we're going to say we're an open
source user if you're a big company and
you're going to sell your software yes
you need a proper license so that's
something to know and here we go we're
just going to download it and get it all
set up and yeah so i'm going to show you
how to do it with cute creator click
side point here
we use our vc package manager and just
do a search for cute
all of the cute libraries well maybe not
all but most of the important cute
libraries you could just go download and
use on your own without their ide they
are available there's cute bass and
there's a bunch of other ones
so typically you want just the probably
the base one or maybe this application
framework then there's a lot of extras
for things you might want to do they
have a lot of support here
so it's
cute is very well fleshed out as far as
how much it's being worked on and being
designed
so now that this download has finished
what we're gonna do here is just launch
it and let it do its thing it's gonna
want us to log in i'm not sure if this
is required or not so i'm going to play
around with this a little bit but
basically you've got to go through the
install
and get it all set up to use their ide
all right so i did already have an
account from a long time ago that i just
used so it does look like to use their
ide you do need an account with them and
i'm pretty sure you don't i feel like
you don't absolutely need it i know i've
installed q creator on linux and i don't
remember signing in so maybe it's just a
windows thing or this particular
installer that i'm using feel free to
leave corrections in the comments if you
know better
so you do have to say that you're not
using it for a company for the free
version so you gotta agree to those
terms and it looks like we can just move
forward go through the setup it's going
to install a lot of components and
libraries so it is going to take a while
to go through all this but we've
installed cube create maybe we should
read the readme let's go ahead and do
that here it is
and we don't see a whole lot of details
they have a list of known issues in
design studio and they have something
called a cute bridge for adobe photoshop
sketch okay interesting well we're going
to launch youtube creator
and when we launch it this is the screen
we get now we do have the option to take
a ui tour i'd recommend doing that if
you're not too familiar with things
but i've used this quite a few times so
i'm not
really concerned i know where to find
things in general
but it's a pretty straight forward menu
set up at the top some buttons on the
side run buttons down here
search and some more stuff down here for
your filing tests and whatnot so there
are no examples here we could go grab
some or we could review oh there's also
user guides here blogs online community
account get cute all right there's also
marketplace there are tutorials these
might be very nice once you get things
set up if you're interested in going
further
and there are projects so you can manage
new open we're gonna do a new project
and we have some options we get a
widgets application which is uh you know
some basic buttons and bars or we can do
a console application so the widgets is
going to give us a window
console
is probably not
you can use this without using the q
libraries this editor is not too bad i
actually used it for quite a while these
are all templates so you can go through
them and try them out if you want
it's uh just some starter stuff but if
you're doing any of these specific
things in general
it wouldn't hurt to start with one of
these and you can remove what you don't
need to start editing
we are going to just do a widget
application because i think that is the
main use to show off
we have an option for build system qmake
make is essentially their version of
cmake discuss with special
configurations but if we want we could
just use cmake or qbs we're going to
stick with qmake for now and let them
manage it and now we have a starter
class now this is as it says here the
basic information about the classes you
wish to generate skeleton source code
files for and see you see by default it
gives us main window for the base class
of qt main window we can change this to
widget or dialog
a main window is going to give us what
you would expect a window for this os
and a widget i believe will too but i
think it's just a different starter
setup
so let's do the main window and we have
the option to generate form and this
form is a ui file this is what it's
going to pull everything from as far as
the layout of your buttons and windows
so we can design that separately from
the code translation file we're not
going to worry about this for now and
kits this is where you select what you
want to compile with and now we see that
we have no suitable kits looks like the
most likely answer to our problem is
that
qt creator wants you to use compiler
listed under one of their cute libraries
use the maintenance tool to install this
excellent
all right so we're going to go to the
maintenance tool
here it is add or remove components
under cute there's cute 6.2.1
your version may vary this appears to be
the latest one at the time of this
recording and it looks like it does
specify some 64-bit msvc ming gw and
some other stuff so we're going to grab
that
not going to worry about the older ones
we can go get them if we need to for
backwoods compatibility later
but i think that's all we're going to
add here with the maintenance tool
this could have been done at install but
this is a nice lesson for in case you
miss it this is how you go back you just
gotta use the maintenance tool
that is now finished we have the option
to restart or finish here restart only
restarts this process so we've added the
new library we can now launch cube
creator again and we should be able to
now compile things
[Music]
very good so it has some stuff at the
bottom i'm not going to worry about that
we're just going to go to new project
widgets
name doesn't matter for now we just want
to make sure it actually finds the kits
and now it does find some kids here all
right and it looks like we've got one
selected that'll work for desktop i
think it's actually the same as this
they probably point to the same thing
but yet let's use the cute one there's
also arm gw no android kits okay very
good so we're just gonna hit next here
no version control for now and here we
have all the pre-generated source files
including the form so when you open up
this form this is where you get a ui
layout and you can do what you want so
we're going to put a button here in the
center and you'll see what happens we'll
hit save
uh and the main window in the main and
well let's start from the main so you
see it includes queue application and of
course main window which is our other
file the cue application is mainly what
we need here so instantiates a new one
instantiates a window then it does show
now this main window if we look at it
it's got some
cute stuff here
uh mainly a class called a main window
that inherits from cue main window and
uh declares a cue object i forget
exactly how this is it's just a macro
you can see it all there does some
special behind the scenes stuff for cute
and we have a main window
that can take a parent
on instantiation and we have our ui set
up here so if we go to the cbp file we
will see
that it's going to use this
mainwindow.ui and i believe it just does
that automatically based on its name
it's got ui underscore main window so
somehow this form is included i'm not
entirely sure how but i think it's
through this include
but you can just custom make them as
well or here we go it's on the untitled
or it's going to be your project name
dot pro so this has your project set up
just like all the details of your
project so that q make knows how to
handle things basically and we see that
it is listed as a form as well as config
for c plus plus 11. we're just gonna hit
play this should just work out of the
box with a default case here and there
we go we've got our push button of
course our push button isn't hooked up
to any functions or anything and that's
what you're kind of going to need to
know next the designer has its own side
of things
and
the hooking these up with code has a
side of things but this designer is
super nice
you can do all sorts of stuff with it
you get properties for any button you
click on over here for special settings
and all of these settings everything you
can do in this designer you can also do
with c plus plus code so you don't
necessarily have to use this designer or
this ui file and also you can make
changes to these on the fly with your c
plus plus code and you could just have
their default setup in the ui
if that makes sense so yeah you can have
the default setup in the ui and then you
can use the code later in your project
as logic happens to change ui elements
that's a little more advanced i don't
think we're going to quite get that far
but just letting you know the
possibilities so
if you want to see a tutorial on cute
designer stuff and best practices i
could do that but i'm not going to do
that in this video because it would just
be a big side track but highly encourage
you play around with it if you're
curious
let's put some stuff up here but
and now let's hit like save all you
could see
oh down here it tells you the build
status
there we go now we have file and about
here and uh push button
all right
so where do you go from here now this is
where you decide what am i trying to do
what kind of app am i building and you
kind of go from here basically and you
can make more of these windows if you
need to and you can do all sorts of
stuff with them
so really from here it's up to you how
much documentation you want to go look
at how many cute tutorials you want to
look at and
really what you want to build at this
point
it is also like it's just c plus plus
knowledge you're going to run into a lot
of c plus plus concepts you're managing
this stuff
all right well i hope this helped you
get started with cute creator this is
available on all os's so
you can make some nice cross-platform
guise and work on it in different os is
you just have to set up that kits and
compilers
with whatever you're working with and
pick one that's working for your os but
the code should be all the same and
that's one of the beauties of this
library thank you for watching i really
appreciate it and i want to take a
moment to say thanks to all of you
there's a lot of you out there who show
me a lot of
thanks and gratitude especially in the
comments
and i really appreciate that like more
than you know some days it does help me
keep going because uh like you i am also
living through the human
experience you would you could say
and
to those of you that go further beyond
i really appreciate it too people on
patreon the people that have joined
um
i only have one tier and it is basically
three bucks so if you would like to
support me by buying me a coffee or tea
or a beer every month
you can sign up on patreon and do so or
hit the join button
on
youtube and that would mean
a ton to me as well
these productions do take a lot of time
especially to keep going and
come up with new stuff
and all the editing
so it really does make a huge difference
for me continuing
to grow here
and make this a viable stable thing for
me so i really appreciate you guys
and i'll be uh
i'll be out there also we have a discord
going where
you can talk about anything code related
pretty much and we have a small
community of coders that is growing so
would love it if you would like to join
or join
uh
you can tell i feel really awkward given
these sort of
talks but
i do mean it and i should say it more
often
so i'm gonna at least try to slip it in
here like once a month
and uh see if we can get some more
people
in the community
doing stuff because at some point we're
going to be doing some awesome things
who knows what
we might have some little code
competitions or something at some point
but uh yeah all things computer science
pretty much gonna be on this channel
going forward
since that is my main interest all right
i appreciate you guys see you next
episode peace
[Music]